you've worked with so many great people
but we lost Carrie Fisher not too long
ago you work with Carrie Fisher on the
wedding singer yes because she did great
punch up on specs right and she helped
out did yes yes she was a great I mean
we all loved her we all like the fact
that she was you know drew loved her I
loved her everyone working on the movie
loved her and we got close with the
Carrie and when she was doing the
rewrites on our movie she has his famous
party in town she used to have this
famous probably everybody would come all
these giant celebrities and I got she
invited us and you're kind of I mean
you've got you've been at you were kind
of a new star at that yeah not really
not really big enough to be at that
party so she invited us we show up to
the party by the way the first person we
see at this party all of a sudden you
hear love it's anything anyways we get
there and like it's it's just the
biggest stars we grew up with in the
world and Pacino's there and just all
these women that we've loved over the
years and then Harrison Ford you know
Harrison he's a great man I know I mean
realize that ISM like the most iconic
movie story you can imagine right is
Harrison Ford exactly and I'm like 25 or
whatever the hell I was I was like and
then Harrison Ford looks at me and he's
like I was like oh man what's happening
right now and Harrison Ford like excuse
me I like is that you kind of thing I
was like yeah and then he comes over and
he's like you're the guy from the the
Billy Madison I go yeah yeah yeah he
goes I would love for you to come over
to my house and I say yeah and then he
goes and I would love for you to wash my
car
[Laughter]
because my kids think you're funny and
it would just be such a kick for them to
see that and I say okay that's crazy
yeah but you know Paris you could get
away with that yeah you can do anything
else you just done
you